this is disturbing to say the least
these are kids parents took them to this
the audio is taken out on Twitter don't
worry about let it keep playing you know
it's also discussions are sitting there
by the way he thinks that this is okay
the person doing these moves think look
at this like it's disgusting I don't
care if he thinks it's okay the parents
think this is okay let him think this
was okay I'm okay with that I don't have
a problem if he thinks it's okay those
parents who have their kids in there
tell me what the kid is learning like
what form of entertainment is this
it's not entertaining to me at all this
is like what adult adults used to go in
a bachelorette party grown adults and
see this stuff and now you have small
children well because again you have to
like you have to pause this you have to
not it's not about normalizing the
behavior like these are grown adults can
do whatever they want grown adults can
also go and spend money to go see
whatever they want right it's about
normalizing exposure of these things to
small children and it's it's deeply sick
but what is wrong with that generation
like what is the age bracket of parents
that have lost their minds here is it I
think it's like parents in there what
20s 30s and maybe even early 40s that
are doing this stuff because I can't
think of anyone above that age bracket
that I know of that thinks this is sane
but I do know some people in places like
New York City who are in their 30s or
whatever that oh yeah this is just
what's happening in the world and would
take their kids to stuff like this so I
don't know man something's deeply sick
going on Tom what what does somebody
have to pay you for you to take your
kids to that entertainment to see
something like that how much money
there there's no amount of money you can
give me same here what what is the
outcome of someone like that you know
like confusion confusion in the mind of
those kids you know
um because you see something like this
there you know it's like a sentence
there's got to be a subject a predicate
and you know a DOT at the end of the
sentence and so what are you telling the
kids when they're going in to see this
what are they seeing what are they
interpreting what do they think it's all
about and who's who's talking with them
later you know which what's really
interesting is you take third graders
second graders into a school play and
the school play is about the
Revolutionary War and then what do we do
we go back to the classroom we talk
about the play we saw and we debrief a
little bit it's called learning right
something at the front of the class then
reflective discussions and then write
something take a test all those things
do you don't understand you're they're
just walking out with confusing pbd
confusion you know what I mean there's
no debriefing how many of your kids they
see something at school they see a film
on Ben Franklin they come home with a
book on Ben Franklin they debrief from
Ben Franklin and then they sit down and
they write a little piece of homework so
there's this full circle coming around
when kids go in to watch that what did
you tell them you were going to watch
what did they think when they saw it and
what did you debrief afterwards you
there's I would I want to finish with
this I want to and I appreciate that
time I want to finish with this Frank
from you from Jed from Tom so somebody's
watching this and they're saying this is
freaking ridiculous I got two kids let's
just say 40 year old and an
eight-year-old okay
I got three kids a nine a 12 and a 15
year old but I only make 73 000 a year I
can't afford to put my kids in private
school and I can't afford to stay home
because my job doesn't allow me to work
from home I have to go to my work
I don't have a lot of choices and I I'm
starting my part-time real estate gig to
try to make some money so I can put my
kids in private school but I don't have
any say when I go to my school I'm in
such a liberal left community that
there's nothing I feel like there's
nothing I can do there's 20 of us
parents that we all know each other
because we go to the same church what
can I do what do you say to those
parents Jed honestly what do I say yeah
both
that's what I say I know it's hard I I
know and I I understand I grew up with
very little money
um my parents didn't have a lot of money
they had to work very very very hard to
get everything that they have in life
and they made decisions based on
sometimes you just have to go if you are
in a very liberal place and the school
districts are terrible you got to figure
out a way to to get out if you can't do
the private school and you can't do the
homeschooling some families you know are
able to make sacrifices and say the dad
goes to work and there's a stay-at-home
mom and she says I'm going to take this
responsibility on not everybody can do
that some people are in situations where
they need two incomes coming in I
understand it all I also understand that
moving is not easy that there's you know
you have families where you are you have
your home you have there's a lot but but
this is not going this is not going to
get any better in these blue cities
these blue States it's it's moving in
this direction of these videos that
we've seen today and worse so you have
to make a decision at some point of what
matters and ultimately if you are
stressed just every single day that you
send your kids into a school and you're
coming home with a different kid you've
got to consider picking up and going to
a state where there's at least some
parental right protections where you
know you have a say in your kid's life
when they're not in your home Frank yeah
I would um argue and I would just advise
them to if you can move do so
um and then you also just have to play
an active role in what your child is
learning I I'm a huge proponent that you
should ask your children and be involved
in the things that they're learning so
you can course correct these actions and
the earlier that you can course correct
it it's very important when it comes to
you know what happens in your hometown
um gays against rumors is expanding so
quickly we get so many applications for
volunteers go to our website and see if
we have a chapter there we will deploy
someone over there to advocate for you
and shield you from these things like we
do all across our country and just
definitely just play that active role
and make sure that there are great
feedback Tom and the answer is
once you have kids you
you have to decide what you're going to
do with any spare minute of time is it
your hobbies is it your desires or are
you going to invest in this uh in this
wonderful child that you've been trusted
with and being as close to them as you
can so that you can guide with
Frameworks is point one point two is I
won't repeat it it's everything judge
has said but I think point one is just
making an avowed commitment every spare
minute I you know I don't have hobbies
it's one of the things my kids have
noticed when we were living in Dallas
and said you know Dad you don't go with
your friends to the OU football game
that's not a bad thing but I knew a lot
of guys would get these big RVs that
would go up and be gone for the weekend
for the OU football game now remember
there's only what five six home games
for OU it wasn't happening every week
but they noticed that my time was with
them not dotam what a thing you just
said so everybody hit a different point
yours was move if you can because the
fear of going to school and every day
you're like my kids is going to change
when they come home that's a real
sincere fear that people have yours is
get active be involved yours has dropped
some of the happies that are hobbies
that are not necessary you have to go to
this you have to go to that I'm going to
go to this game I'm going to drive to
this and you're missing 18 hours of
being with your kids all great feedback
I will say this to you
and this is not going to be popular
all parents love their kids I'm
convinced of course some of them that go
and didn't want the responsibility the
father lives and does parents that are
in their kids lives they love their kids
but let's face it parents
you ain't gonna like what I'm telling
you this just kind of receive it
sometimes you're a little lazy to want
to do your job as a parent it's it's an
as a leader as believe me I was a sales
leader and I didn't want to do
accountability calls how many calls did
you make this week I forget about it I
was a lazy leader in my 20s then I
realized accountability is necessary to
develop better leaders parents how was
your day today what did you talk about
what did they bring up what did you
watch who did you befriend did you have
any tea did you think do this dude
playing stuff for them to kind of give
you feedback and realize you got to keep
an eye out for this you got to choose
this what about this talk to the
teachers email teachers trust me I if I
were to get a Leader's bulletin of how
many times parents email teachers to say
what happened to your the more teachers
know that the parent is involved just
like that abuser said earlier the more
involved the father is the less I do my
thing the more involved you are the less
the teacher knows that they can't mess
with that family they got to know that
this stuff is important to you so I
think some of it is also on parents not
being lazy to be involved because your
life is so busy with a show you're
watching with a Netflix with a sports
team you're loyal to
etc etc there's nothing more valuable
for you to be loyal to than the future
of your kids that you brought onto this
world okay you're gonna need God's help
you're gonna need community help but
most importantly outside of those two
you also need to lead them properly by
being involved so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]